We go to places like Google, YouTube and other search engines regularly to find
answers to questions like where's a good restaurant to eat at?
How do you fix a bike? And to track down the most recent gossip on a popular
celebrity. But an important question is why do we go there with our questions?
I think the answer is because we believe at least generally that we'll find helpful,
reliable answers to our questions.
In 1 Peter 3:15, the Apostle Peter says to sanctify Christ as
Lord in our hearts, to always be ready with an answer for the hope within and to
give it with gentleness and give it with respect.
Here's a question that's important for us to think about.
What would it take for you and me to live the kind of life that would invite
questions from other people? How do we live our lives in a certain way where others
want to know the source of our hope?
And what are some questions we can ask other people to help them along their
spiritual journeys? A few years ago, I co-wrote a book called Is God Just a Human
Invention with a friend of mine named Jonathan Morrow.
The goal was to provide succinct and yet thoughtful answers to the 17 biggest
questions skeptics and atheists were asking about God.
While Christians were reading it I was getting a good response but I started to
think to myself how could I get other non-believers to read it and engage with the
ideas. So I called up one of the largest skeptic groups near where I live I told the
head I said I'd be happy to come sit in the hot seat of your group and just answer
questions that you and some of the other skeptics in your group would have towards a
Christian. I went up there and they had questions about the existence of God,
questions about the Bible, political questions and even specific questions what I
believed about the soul. It was a blast.
Before the event began, I'd asked the leader if it was okay towards the end if I
could ask them some questions. Now I could have asked this group of skeptics how
they explain the origin of information in DNA or the origin of the universe or how they
explain the evidence for the resurrection of Jesus.
While those are great questions, I decided to take a different approach.
Instead of asking questions like what blind spots do Christians have?
What bad impressions do Christians often leave?
And how can Christians improve their interaction with skeptics?
And I'll never forget a lady sitting right in the front to my right.
She was maybe 70 years old. She said, listen.
I said, tell me what you mean. She said, a lot of my Christian friends want to speak
to me. Tell me why I'm wrong. Preach the gospel at me.
Occasionally tell me I'm going to hell.
But when I want to share my beliefs, they don't want to listen to me.
why should I listen to them when they don't listen to me the fellow in the back
who's maybe 50 years old who described himself as a former Christian he said stop
slandering atheists and I said well that's a pretty serious charge what do you mean
he said look I'm an atheist but occasionally I'll just show up and I'll go to church
people don't know who I am or why I'm there I just listen he said almost every time
I show up I hear some cheap shot often from the stage about atheists or some
other non-Christian group.
Here's the bottom line. If we don't treat non-believers the way that Christ calls us
to, they so often won't even hear what we believe is true.
You see, the Bible tells us that Jesus came in grace and he came in truth.
He came in grace which is in a loving relationship and he also spoke truth.
We are called to speak truth.
We can't compromise truth, but we must do it in love.
If we mess up the relationship so often people won't even hear what we believe is
true. If we want people to ask us questions about our faith, we need to be living
the kind of lives that invite inquiry.
We need to be living the kind of lives that makes people wonder what is the source
of that person's hope? But we also need to be ready with some thoughtful questions
we can ask other people to help them along on their spiritual journeys.
Here's some specific questions that I found helpful in my own experience and
relationships.
First, what do you believe? It's important to find out what the other person
believes.
Proverbs 18:13 says it is foolish and shameful to answer before you hear.
to have an honest conversation with somebody we first have to understand what that
person really believes and that person is only going to share what they believe when
we ask good questions and really listen second why do you believe it what
reasons does the person have for his or her beliefs Proverbs 20 verse 5 says that
the purpose in a man's heart is like deep water but it takes a person of
understanding who can draw it out.
In other words, people have deep reasons for why they believe as they do and
sometimes people know those reasons sometimes they don't.
Take my father for example before he became a Christian he was an angry agnostic.
He looked for ways to shoot Christians down and prove that they were wrong.
One thing he didn't fully realize at the time is he would hear people talk about a
Heavenly Father and he thought why would I want a Heavenly Father.
That idea turned him off. Why? Because his earthly father was abusive
and absent. His relationship with his father was a deep reason
that gave him some anger against God.
People have deep reasons for why they believe as they do, and it takes wisdom and
listening and patience to help draw out what those real reasons often are.
The third question is where do we agree where can we find common ground
finding common ground is a powerful way to have meaningful spiritual conversations
with other people when we find common ground often someone's guard will go down and
they'll listen in a way they wouldn't have listened before when i was meeting with
these skeptics they were surprised to find out even though we clearly differ on a
number of significant issues how much we actually have in common and the
fourth question is where do we disagree I've had at least two
significant spiritual conversations with skeptics about the origin of the universe
and each of these conversations we talked about the science and the philosophy that
points towards the universe having a beginning as we got back to really the
basis of the argument, I said to him, I said, either you have to believe that the
universe can come into existence from nothing or you believe there's a cause outside
of space, outside of time that speaks the universe into existence.
Which do you find more reasonable?
And both of them looked me right in the eyes and said, a universe from nothing is
most reasonable. Now, in some ways, I'm not exactly sure where to take the argument
from that. So I just said back to him i said okay here's where you and i differ i
think it's more reasonable there's a god who speaks the universe into existence you
think it's more reasonable that something can come from nothing all i was trying to
do was clarify the cost of being an atheist now interestingly in
a matter of time one of them actually became a believer in my
experience most people are willing to have genuine spiritual conversations
if we treat people the way they want to be treated they'll often return the favor to
us if we really listen to people and value their opinions most people will listen
back and value what we have to say as well you have learned some powerful
lessons in this study and you are ready for spiritual conversations now I don't
think you have to have all the answers.
I don't have even close to all the answers.
If someone asks you a tough question, just simply say, I don't know, and then go
find an answer so you'll know next time.
If you're willing to ask good questions, listen to people and stick with people
through their journeys. I think you'll be amazed at how God will use you in people's
lives to make a difference with them spiritually.
Go for it.